eco tristan ça fait cinq ans que
journaliste j'ai un dea d'économie
publique un rouleau master d'économie
appliquée et tu fais du violent aussi
est marié
ehpad et engagement se passionne on
voudrait bien se voir comme ça de temps
en temps soit pour le plaisir le plaisir
de qui en fait j'aurais base une limace
sous anesthésie générale c'était un peu
pareil le le probable bref je suis dit
je vais devenir le meilleur qu'août
paris ben comme le groupe le monde
ile-de-france même jusqu à montargis à
montargis formidable de sexe pour les
tocards qui et je dirai la base des
héros prévient cette très et cuit le
sexe en période de crise président c'est
moi qui prend aussi des récupérer le
numéro de metz cordiale selon vous êtes
hayat
est-ce que 500 clients ont c'est un
buteur un mec c'est toi de le regarder
bien du bric et pousse au cul chaque
particule de ton corps de penser qu
indique qu donc vous visez la
performance en six ans j'ai
personnellement mis au point un coaching
pour former des expertes du v ça d'un
trait avant l'acte j'allais vivre un
moment merveilleux
c'est toute façon on s'en fout c'est pas
nous qui prédit sur les textes histoires
de cul est mal dosée et quand patrick on
avait couché ensemble
on n'a pas couché en salle bah pas du
tout plutôt mourir
il faut se mettre dans une vraie logique
d'entraînement ne pourrait pas
fonctionner au coup par coup et vient de
voir les scores d'avant je pense qu'elle
fait ça pour payer ses études normales
c'est que les mecs ils doivent brûler
des cierges pour qu'elle redouble un
noceur